[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
los bolivianos vuelven a votar este
domingo en unas elecciones generales que
buscan cerrar la grave crisis política
generada por las elecciones de octubre
pasado en las que hubo acusaciones de
fraude
evo morales tuvo que exiliarse y se
generó una confrontación con al menos 30
muertos hubo o no fraude en esos
comicios con la vuelta a las urnas se
podrá cerrar esta crisis para analizarlo
hoy hace escala en parís el ex canciller
ecuatoriano jefe de observación de la
oea en las elecciones judiciales en
bolivia en 2017 y actualmente analista
político guión long muchísimas gracias y
bienvenidos gracias por la invitación y
guillaume long usted nació cerca de
parís es franco británico y ecuatoriano
fue ministro de rafael correa- canciller
también embajador ante la onu hasta que
dejó el cargo por diferencias con el
actual presidente ecuatoriano lenin
moreno y actualmente trabaja para él
de investigación en economía y política
con sede en washington que publicó un
informe en el que contradicen la
denuncia de la oea sobre el supuesto
fraude en las elecciones de 2019 en
bolivia en que se basan para decir que
la oea se equivoca bueno nos dimos
cuenta enseguida realmente el día
después de las elecciones que la hoya
estaban haciendo declaraciones que no se
basaban en un análisis riguroso sobre
todo la parte estadística no era muy
sospechoso decían cosas que realmente la
oea que tiene generalmente un bagaje
técnico tiene una capacidad técnica en
sus misiones de observación electoral
que yo las conozco desde adentro y que
ha sido reconocido a nivel mundial y
esta vez era como muy extraño el
comportamiento de la hoya nos pusimos de
estudiar porque decían que había habido
un cambio drástico y difícil de
justificar esto lo que dijeron al día
siguiente un cambio drástico y difícil
de justificar en la votación después de
la interrupción del sistema preliminar
de conteo de los votos pues nos pusimos
a hacer un análisis estadístico a ver si
es que había
este cambio drástico y difícil de
justificar de la votación y vimos que en
realidad hubiese sido posible para la
oea predecir el resultado final que
finalmente anunció el tribunal supremo
electoral que no había ningún cambio
drástico en la votación que lo que
sucedió fue que con el 84% de los votos
contados evo morales tenía una
diferencia de 7.9 por ciento sobre el
siguiente siguiente rival carlos meza es
decir menos del 10 puntos que necesitaba
para evitar una segunda vuelta pero ya
con cada vez más más mayor cantidad de
votos ingresando y acercándonos al cien
por ciento él logró pasar el umbral de
los diez puntos para poder ganar las
elecciones de una segunda vuelta porque
porque como en todos los procesos
electorales bolivianos de los últimos
años ingresa el voto rural el voto
periférico el voto de algunas de las
zonas más pobres del país de forma más
tardía entonces
a medida que vamos avanzando en el
conteo el voto es más cargado a favor
del más el partido de morales entonces
claro hacia el final ingresaron muchos
votos favorables dar más
pasar el umbral de los 10 puntos de
diferencia que necesitaba para ganar en
primera vuelta eso lo hicimos nosotros
fuimos los primeros en hacerlo luego lo
hicieron otros académicos otros
estadísticos de varias universidades en
los eeuu llegaron a hacer también una
revisión de nuestros análisis 133
estadísticos de nivel mundial que
publicaron una carta pública denunciando
la mala práctica incluso usaron la
palabra el engaño estadístico de la oea
sobre ese engaño luego se construye
digamos una auditoría posterior y hacen
un análisis de supuestas irregularidades
también hemos demostrado en otros info
son varios informes nuestros que estos
que estas supuestas irregularidades no
constituyen lo que ya llama la oea una
manipulación intencional de la votación
de los bolivianos para poner en
antecedentes a nuestra audiencia según
la versión oficial en esas elecciones
evo morales iba ganando como usted dice
se paraliza el conteo de votos se retoma
un día después y luego se declara
ganador
la oposición denuncia fraude fraude la
oea también se llama la oea para esa
auditoría y en su informe de 100 páginas
afirman que
y fraude a través de servidores ocultos
de datos comprobantes de votación
manipulados firman firmas falsas
rellenaban actas la misma persona
tengo dos preguntas una es porque se
paraliza el conteo rápido de votos que
es lo que empieza a provocar sospechas
en la oposición y tienen constancia de
irregularidades ustedes reconocen que
hubo irregularidades yo creo que es muy
importante entender que todos los
procesos electorales del mundo tiene
irregularidades las hay en eeuu las hay
en francia las hay obviamente en los
países de américa latina donde a veces
hay problemas de institucionalidad
nosotros nunca dijimos no ha habido
irregularidades en bolivia pero la
propia oea siempre establece una gran
diferencia quien ha sido observador de
la oea hasta le entrenan para eso de que
no cada vez que vea una irregularidad
tiene que gritar fraude muchas de las
irregularidades se las tienen que
informar se hace incluso un informe
final de la oea para que las autoridades
electorales del país puedan mejorar sus
procesos gran parte de la observación es
eso
para que las irregularidades signifiquen
una manipulación intencional tiene que
ser realmente comprobado que estas
irregularidades fueron intencionales en
primer lugar hay una verdadera intención
y segundo que cambiaron el resultado la
oea en ningún momento demuestra eso
muchas de las personas que se abanderan
hoy del informe de la oea o no lo han
leído bien o realmente no lo entendieron
porque la oea en ningún momento
demuestra que esas irregularidades
algunos incluso cuestionar y amos y en
realidad son irregularidades pero
algunas de las cosas que señala la oea
son intencional e intencionales en
primer lugar y cambiar el resultado el
tema de las firmas realmente es una
burla no estamos hablando de 226 actas
de un total de 30.000 actas a nivel de
país en donde la persona que firma el
acta
no hicieron análisis caligráfico y no ha
puesto su nombre y estamos hablando en
lugares muy hicimos un análisis de todas
estas actas
estamos hablando de centros de votación
muy alejados en lugares donde no todo el
mundo necesariamente los jurados
escriben bien no hay altos tasas de
analfabetismo problemas además donde el
español no es el primer idioma sea o de
denota una falta de análisis
antropológico total y si es que esto es
prueba de fraude no vale ninguna
elección en américa latina no realmente
hay forzaron muchavista regularidad y
bueno podríamos analizar así caso por
caso el tema los servidores claro suena
muy escandaloso es que estar mis
servidores escondidos hoy sabemos que el
famoso servidor era del contratista que
hacía el ingreso de los votos del tren
del voto preliminar una persona además
para nada favorable al más no lograron
pudieron hacer un análisis del servidor
nunca lo hicieron para demostrar que
allí se había cambiar los datos no
lograron demostrar es etcétera etc
y entonces por qué la empeño de la oea
en denunciar fraude bueno esa es la gran
pregunta nosotros en la
el análisis que hacemos no es un
análisis político es un análisis técnico
miramos prueba por prueba prueba entre
comillas de la oea analizamos es que
realmente demuestran fraude luego
debería haber un mayor análisis
periodístico espero que no tengamos que
esperar a los historiadores para que nos
cuenten exactamente qué pasó casa dentro
de la oea pero para mí y ahí un poco se
están distanciando en el trabajo técnico
y poniendo en el sombrero más político
hubo mano política está claro yo o sea
que que el secretario general de la oea
luis almagro haya dicho sí o se haya
usado además la palabra fraude que es un
poco un tabú para la oea ellos usan un
lenguaje más técnico y que luego ahora a
pesar de todas las críticas que ha
habido a pesar del consenso académico
que hay en los eeuu en europa se
estudiado menos pero en eeuu hay un
consenso académico en todas las
universales que estudiado el tema de que
la oea hizo una mala práctica en su
observación bueno a pesar de eso luis
almagro vuelve a enviar al mismo jefe de
misión que observó las últimas
direcciones de la oea y lo vuelve a
enviar en estas en estas nuevas
direcciones ahora que vamos a tener el
18 de octubre es un acto de provocación
es un acto eminentemente político y nos
hace sospechar de que si hubo mano
política en esta observación del 2010 y
estamos hablando de bolivia un país
altamente polarizado no en el que evo
morales estuvo 13 años en el poder con
victorias muy muy holgadas si embargo
hay una votación que perdió en 2016 con
el referendo el no a la reelección ganó
con un total de 51 3% y aún así se
presentó a las elecciones
usted cree que fue un mal cálculo
político que se equivocó evo morales
porque finalmente tal vez ahí empezó a
haber sospecha suspicacias de la
oposición que se quiere eternizar en el
poder no empieza ahí tal vez la crisis
aparte de el episodio de la de las
denuncias de fraude pero ese no empieza
hay un poco la crisis en bolivia le
hacía falta a evo morales presentarse
cuando había perdido ese referéndum no
sin duda estos radical hizo muchísimo la
oposición fue una fuente de polarización
muy importante a pesar de que después
tuvo una sentencia del tribunal
constitucional y hubo todo un debate
nacional sobre el tema de la reelección
el referendo lo había perdido y cuando
llegan a las elecciones del 2019 había
digamos una gran polarización en la
sociedad boliviana entre los votantes
está claro por eso yo argumentaría que
el digamos del bueno la oea se aprovechó
de estas circunstancias no hizo un
trabajo técnico evaluando si realmente
las elecciones fueron libres y
desde el momento que la oea es parcial
completamente el momento que la voy a
aceptar y observar estas elecciones ya
lo otro no tiene que entrar ni en cuenta
eleva a observar las elecciones y tiene
que decir si esas elecciones son libres
y democráticas o no está realmente
absolutamente parcial y se aprovechó
digamos de ésta yo diría esta ventana de
oportunidad que hubo a través de d
de la situación política boliviana que
era muy polarizada luego usted también
habló de la interrupción del tren que
fue complicada al momento en que se
interrumpió esto le permitió digamos a
la oea aprovechar esta interrupción para
generar suspicacias sobre el proceso
electoral y lograron bueno yo sí creo
realmente que usar las palabras que son
no sembrar un escenario para que pueda
prosperar un golpe de estado y próspero
el golpe de estado y la oea es un actor
fundamental en este golpe de estado como
de las elecciones de este domingo esta
vuelta a las urnas puede poner fin a
esta crisis política si puede poner fin
esta crisis política o la puede alargar
si hay elecciones libres y democráticas
en bolivia es evidente que está agrada
esta gran crisis política y este año de
gobierno de facto no el gobierno no
electo del gobierno de transición se
autodenomina en ellos pero ha sido una
transición bastante larga
que ha sido además tan nefasto para muy
bueno para la democracia para los
derechos humanos ha habido muchos
atropellos de los derechos humanos ya
denunciados incluso por organizaciones
que no eran favorables a morales para
nada bueno se podría poner fin a esta
ojalá en un paréntesis bastante nefasto
en la historia de bolivia y se podría
avanzar con gobierno legítimamente
electo el 18 de octubre o en primera
vuelta o en segunda vuelta el problema y
es que si hay temores de que estas
elecciones no sean libres y democráticas
lastimosamente estamos viendo un
escenario preelectoral con mucha
violencia mucha violencia en las calles
sobre todo hay que decirlo en contra de
los simpatizantes del mar y de los actos
de campaña del más hay un discurso de
intimidación desde el poder desde
especial arturo murillo el ministro de
gobierno y puede puede darse el caso que
la noche de las elecciones
hallan violencia como hubo el año pasado
hay que recordar que el año pasado hubo
hasta quema de tribunales electorales
departamentales y si es que hay
destrucción de material electoral
podríamos estar en un escenario donde no
se puede computar los votos de uno no se
puede contar los votos y por ende se
anulan las elecciones y por ende otra
vez estamos en un escenario de facto y
no estamos en un escenario democrático
bueno pues seguiremos muy pendientes de
lo que pase en bolivia muchísimas
gracias guillaume long ex canciller
ecuatoriano por haber estado con
nosotros y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
que nos pueden seguir por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en france24 punto com
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]